هل سوف يكون يحضر الرئيس مغفورا علما بما
انه رئيس سابق لن يتم وضع الاصوات ولكن قد
يطلب هو مثلا كما قال البعض
لازم ان غرفه اخبار الجزيره مرحبا بكم
هيئه محلفين في نيويورك تصوت لتوجيه اتهام
على خلفيه تحقيق بشان التستر على دفعه
اموال لتغيير مسار تحقيق قضائي محامي
الرئيس السابق توقع استدعائه الاسبوع
المقبل واكد انه لن يقر بالاتهامات
المواجهه اليه في وقت تشهد نيويورك
استنفارا امنيا خشيه اعمال عنف
بوتين يوقع مرسوما لتحديث عقيده السياسه
الخارجيه يحذر من تنامي مخاطر الصدام بين
دول النوويه واتهامات الروسيه للنيتو
بالسعي لتسخين الوضع والافتعال حرب عالميه
ثالثه في حين اقترحت بيلاروسيا هدنه غير
مشروطه في اوكرانيا وكذا الاتحاد الاوروبي
رغبته في سلام تنسحب بموجبه روسيا من هناك
بعد اعلان سوريا تصدي دفاعاتها الجويه
لهجوم اسرائيلي الحرس الثوري الايراني
يعلن مقتل احد مستشاريه في هجمات استهدفت
ضواحي دمشق ويتوعد بالرد ويصف عمليه القتل
بانها جريمه كونها تنتهك سياده سوريا
الارجنتين تتقدم بطلب رسمي لاستضافه كاس
العالم تحت 20 عاما وذلك بعد ان قام
الفيفا بسحبها من اندونيسيا اثراء رفضها
استقبال الوفد الاسرائيلي ومن المقرر ان
تبدا البطوله في العشرين من ايار مايو
المقبل